le projet a été annoncé en 1962 par le
gouvernement du Québec et les travaux
ont commencé en juillet 1963 avec une
technique révolutionnaire du concepteur
québécois Armand couture
au lieu de creuser sous le lit du fleuve
cette caisson de béton précontrait ont
été coulés au bord du fleuve en calèche
puis transporté par flottage jusqu'à une
tranchée creusée au fond du
Saint-Laurent tout un exploit
[Musique]
l'étanchéité des caissons a été rendu
possible grâce à une couche d'enduit
bitumineux et de fibres de verre ces
caissons ont la taille de la Terre de
football chacun ils ont ensuite été
immergés et assemblés entre autres grâce
au travail exceptionnel de plongeur
autre réalisation la construction de 4
tours de ventilation pour permettre
l'évacuation du monoxyde de carbone et
l'entrée d'air frais et histoire de
réduire les coûts il est décidé que le
tunnel long de près d'un kilomètre et
demi reliera Montréal à l'Île Charron un
pont en béton devrait donc être
construit pour relier l'île à la rive
sud du Saint-Laurent pour réaliser des
travaux de préparation le quartier de
longues pointe et son église à
l'extrémité est de l'île ont été rasés
et plus de 300 familles ont été
expropriés
au fil des années des rénovations
importantes ont eu lieu de 2006 à 2008
la dalle du pont de l'Île Charron a été
refaite et une voix de circulation a été
ajoutée en direction sud
l'accident de circulation le plus grave
et survenu en 1985 un camion poids lourd
en Botti un véhicule provoquant un
incendie le tunnel alors été fermé
pendant un mois pour réparer les dégâts
[Musique]
la construction du pont tunnel a coûté
75 millions de dollars payés en grande
partie par le gouvernement fédéral
cet ouvrage constitue l'un des plus
grands tunnels en béton précontraint au
monde le pont tunnel est nommé en
l'honneur de Louis Hippolyte Lafontaine
qui a été premier ministre du Canada est
de 1842 à 1843 il était originaire de
vous servir il a été inauguré par le
Premier ministre Daniel Johnson le chef
de l'opposition Jean Lesage et le maire
de Montréal Jean-Drapeau le 11 mars 1967
ici jacques Bissonnet Radio-Canada
Montréal